Uh,
so Kenrick,
uh,
you have an amazing life.
You started setting caviar in high end places in Las Vegas and now you propose
shares have ample food,
which is an organic brand of food that is widely democratized and distributed
through micro investments,
uh,
on a very sustainable platform leveraging blockchain.
Uh,
and you're a,
you have a legal background.
You,
you are a former fellow at Stanford law,
um,
and you could on your spare time,
but you don't want to say it in front of everyone at Google,
right?
So that's basically a few things and say I'm done technical particularly in this
room.
So,
um,
the first thing I want to ask you,
because we just use a lot of buzz words there in a very few sentences,
uh,
is the story of Fort Dogs.
So there's a dog from angel list,
a dog from a,
you know,
the tech,
a dog from Wall Street and a street dog,
right?
And all or an old dog.
And the dog from Angelina says,
you know,
when I want more money,
what I do is that I,
I leveraged tokens from a blockchain to do micro investment in startups.
Uh,
uh,
and the dog from Texas.
Wait,
wait,
what's a micro investment in a startup and the dog from Wall Street Days?
Hold on.
What's,
what's blockchain?
Right.
And the dog from the street is what's money?
Cause he hasn't come up with a lot of money his day.
So this is a,
you know,
I don't want it to be a dog eat dog situation.
I wanted to understand every dog's perspective in this.
So how can you make it clear to,
you know,
to every perspective that we can have on this what you're doing exactly in what
your company because you're entrepreneur or founder of republic,
which is a part of AngelList,
what your company does and that every dog would understand.
I lived at hypothetical and I think when it comes to investing is definitely in
a dog eat dog and it's more like jog Fetac we're in this one sense.
I think the easiest way to look at money is that it's a form of energy in a
medium of exchange.
Today we use,
you know,
dollar here,
the pound in England,
but anything can actually be a medium of exchange.
So you need money to drive that energy and grow an idea into a business
conditions necessary.
The question is how do you get more people to do that and how do you break this
energy down into smaller pieces?
And if you can do that through blockchain technology,
then you have that much more energy directed into this ecosystem and net net
more ideas will grow into more businesses.
So the way I look at investing is that if you manage to make,
and to encourage everyone to invest even a tiny amount of money into this whole
ecosystem and they wrecked that Mooney to where they believe the should be in
terms of entrepreneurship and companies and products,
then which is going to have that much more prosperous of an ecosystem overall.
Okay.
So the macro investment part I get from this,
how about the blockchain part?
Like why would you use blockchain for this?
The uh,
currently the reason why we take it would cost probably about 20,
$50,000 minimum if you want to invest into real estate even read is that the
cost of transferring,
of,
uh,
making it possible for people to buy a lot of,
you know,
a stake in a building a home would be so high.
The cross processing of validating,
of confirming your interests and when,
when you want to sell that interest is going to be equally burdensome.
Blockchain technology,
one use case of it is fractionalization and automation.
If you can break the Mona Lisa down into a billion pieces,
you can have a billion people around the world owning a piece of the Mona Lisa.
Yes,
it's only worth probably a fraction of a dollar,
but you owning a piece of the Mona Lisa and there's only able recently to
blockchain technology that you can fractionalize things to that degree and that
it costs next to nothing to transfer a tiny fraction of an assets between two
individuals.
Hmm.
I have a feeling down or the revenue,
she would have loved your idea.
Right?
So,
um,
and be very interested in the mechanism.
So when I get from this is that this micro investment,
which is a form of expression of crowdfunding,
but more organized,
right?
More a on a platform,
you're standing somewhere between crowdfunding and an IPO,
right?
Uh,
there is this middle space that has not really been invested,
if I might use the word before in which,
uh,
initiatives need money.
And why wouldn't you come at this earlier than the formal IPO,
which return investment might not be so,
so high because now there's the technology.
And if I notice where also the regulation for this,
uh,
early investing naturally comes with high risk and much higher return.
So I think most people,
uh,
nowadays this ecosystem know that Uber is about to file for IPO.
People who buying in post IPO,
pretty much anyone who's not a millionaire will see a return or a depreciation.
But you know,
two x three x or 20% loss.
Obviously if you invested $10 in or $100 into Uber is very first round on angel
list today,
that's going to be worth somewhere between 1.5 to $2 million on face value.
So getting in early is definitely a value proposition,
but it wasn't legal.
And two,
2016,
up until two and a half years ago,
you got to be a millionaire to invest in private companies.
And I'm glad that it was very different now.
All right.
And so that's when your legal background comes into play because you knew the
Lao address changed and they do a huge new opportunity for people to invest
because they don't need to have to be certified in investors if I get this
right.
And so then the question is how do we organize this to work efficiently for
everyone,
right?
Am I right in this?
Absolutely.
So obviously the law is there to make sure that people are,
now they're defrauding,
you know,
grandmas and people with very little,
um,
dispensable income.
Now,
on the other hand,
99% of the world of the United States wealthiest country in the world,
99% of people have never made a private investment.
So they don't know what it is.
Everyone had taken a cap or a taxi almost everyone before Uber.
So when they made it possible,
it was just a natural leap.
What we're trying to do is to get everyone to do something that they have never
been done before.
So it's a much more challenging journey from the branding,
marketing exposure,
as well as legal and business.
All right.
So I want your platform as part of the preparation for this talk.
I discovered the breadth of products that you have there.
It's amazing you go from ample food,
which I mentioned,
uh,
to uh,
some more tech startups.
Can you tell us how do you curate the propositions?
Because I still want to know that my daughters are invested in place that is
kind of safer curated,
and I think you'll provide that service a given an angel,
this is our institutional cofounder and our team has a heritage back to the
eventual DVC Lens.
So we do apply some natural lens.
Is their credibility.
Uh,
founders have domain expertise.
On the other hand,
I fundamentally believe that people should invest for any number of reasons.
Maybe they just want to support women founders.
Maybe they want to get some return back from that food truck and not necessarily
a thousand x in a tech company.
So if the vision is to build Amazon for private investing where you have
thousands and thousands of companies and millions and millions of people
participating,
then one of our core focus is to present as many options,
credible,
viable options possible,
and let the crowd follow their heart and their head and make the decision for
themselves.
All right,
so I got a better idea of,
of what you do at republic.
Uh,
you allow everyone to make micro investment even a few dollars without over
heads because the technology's there without legal constraints because the
regulation has changed and there's this new highway of potential investment
open.
Uh,
however,
my mother told me never to gamble.
Uh,
you know,
and,
uh,
I don't know that I've been such a good son,
but,
uh,
what,
what would you say about the risk reward and is this for everyone or is this
something that,
you know,
how do you reassure me that you're not about to create the next subprime crisis
with your idea?
Of course.
Uh,
you know,
even when it comes to gambling,
it's not so much that you should never gamble.
I think that people should do whatever it is they want to do with the fully
aware of the risks and the consequences.
So you know,
the gambling likely's going to result in total loss of money,
but you have a lot of fun doing it and you can afford that $50 at a slot
machine.
By all mean in my opinion,
you should do it.
Obviously the rest of gambling is very high.
Now when it comes to early stage investing,
the risk is still high,
not as high,
but every single year,
about a hundred billion dollars being spent at the casino,
not by millionaires,
mostly by non accredited people,
then at the $80 billion into a lottery tickets.
Can you imagine what the world would be with Silicon Valley and the US and the
world at large would be 10% of that,
$180 billion per year get invested or gambled informally into new innovations
that has that opportunity to change our world.
So basically you're saying,
uh,
the micro investment is worth the risk,
but you have to lose.
It's a few dollars.
Uh,
what is,
what is the average amount of people that people spend on your platform?
If I may a take the answer one question about money.
This is my more like my personal view.
I think generally from what I observe,
how people spend fall into three categories.
One is the basic necessity,
you know,
putting food on the table by toothpaste,
feeding your kids,
you have kids.
The second one is for enjoyment,
for value.
You know,
you go out and buy a nicer jacket.
You necessarily need,
you take a kite surfing lesson and the third one is for growing that capital.
They were able,
they will enable you to do number one and two.
So obviously don't spend any money that you absolutely need to feed yourself and
your family in the casino or in investing for that matter.
When it comes to micro investing,
$100 $500 investing,
not buying a product.
I think it's a blend between two and three.
It is quite satisfying.
If I really believe in that food short founder and her food and her resilience,
then they,
and she decides to fundraise to build a Mexican restaurant and I invest $200
into it.
You know,
if she doesn't make it,
I'm s I'm still rooting for her.
Now if I'm investing $200,000 into it,
I probably want to know that I can get you know,
the money back or that she would be so well that I could make you know,
two or three times as much.
But when it comes to micro investing,
you're going to be,
you would be able to let people gamble or make informed decision and have fun
between two and three.
How,
how is it different from crowdfunding?
Let me give a very quick definition of crowdfunding is a Kickstarter and
Indiegogo whereby you go on and buy a product that hasn't been made.
That's generation one of crowdfunding and that's back in 2008 or so.
Then you have 2011 Angeles came into the mix that allow millionaires to co
invest into tech deals.
So that's the second wave of it.
And when Republic launch in 2016 that allows anyone,
anywhere of any income and net worth invest as little as 10 or $20 into
businesses.
That's crowd investing still crowdfunding.
I think all of us can agree that there's a different psychological attachment
when you invest,
when you have an interest in something compared to buying a product.
I used to work for the guy who founded skyy vodka and I don't think there's a
difference between absolute vodka inside skywalk here,
but if you,
Bryce had made $50 investment into absolute,
when you go out to the bar with me,
at the end of the day you're going to buy me absolute shots,
you're going to serve up that kind of that brand of vodka,
you know,
over the holidays in July 4th so that notion of engagement,
of commitment,
of having skin in the game,
I think is what going to drive crowd investing into a new trend.
And indeed that's the underlying foundation of a token economy of using tokens
to incentivize participants.
All right.
So what I understand is that crowdfunding might be more before there's a
product.
Uh,
micro investment is at the early stage when there is something and you know what
you're investing into,
but you still have attachment because you're in such an early contributor to
this that you want to serve that vote cut your friends are or that strawberry
juice
and then you potentially get that return and share in that outside
growth because this is more a return on investment perspective than the
crowdfunding,
which might be just you're buying something really and paying for it.
Correct.
Uh,
and it's still early enough before there will be a stock exchange play that you
have the huge reward curve if you're investing on the right thing and that your,
your passion and your gut goes along with the market 100%.
All right.
So thank you for all these explanations is already very,
very interesting.
Now I would like to,
uh,
to go on the step further because you are in the middle of a,
of a lot of trends and each of them collide in which we're doing right now.
Uh,
how do you see the future of,
uh,
of investment?
Because,
so let's say that we public is the president of investment because I can go to
there and repair because we have a big.co right?
It's for everyone who wants to not a calm that club come all right.
Uh,
you,
you got rid of the m.
All right.
And then so republic.co and what you are your platform and high works and
operates.
Um,
so I understand the past,
I understand the present and this,
this very new initiative and interesting way to see it.
How do you,
what are you going to launch?
What are you dreaming about?
How do you,
how do you foresee the future?
What is your take on the future investments?
First,
let me just share one tidbit about the presence and the funding landscape.
I don't know how many people even here in at Google and in the heart of Silicon
Valley,
realize that 50%,
five zero of all venture capital go to businesses in California.
But another 50% go to just social apps.
Um,
African American founders,
African American women founders are responsible for $30 billion worth of revenue
businesses founded by African American founders,
uh,
responsible for tens of billions of dollars and statistically 0% get funded on
certain years.
So if we can agree that good ideas exist everywhere,
that no community,
no city,
no heritage has a monopoly on innovations that if funded can mature into the
Google,
the apple of the world 10 and 20 years from now,
then there's a lot of work to get done.
So now to answer your question,
what's the future?
I think the future is indeed that
if not 80 or 90%,
then 50,
60,
70% of adult would look at micro investing,
10 and $20 at a time as a way,
as a new way,
as a new spending behavior similar to or adding onto whatever else they've been
doing.
Think of it as a social engagement,
almost like recycling,
but adding on to that potential for growing the capitol,
that deceiving that you have.
And I think I just,
no question in my mind that Amazon for private investing will be the future,
that people will be investing as easily and quickly and cheaply as buying a
product on Amazon.
And once we get there,
I think we can eradicate global poverty once and for,
because investing in a new day and age when technology reduces not increases
jobs,
how do you lower the income gap by allowing people to invest 10 20,
$30 and have that opportunity to,
you know,
get a major distribution and realize their potential.
Wow.
It's a pretty bold vision.
Thank you for sharing it.
Um,
one thing that I forgot to ask you,
how do you make money for republic out of,
out of this?
Like where you know,
how do,
how does your system operate financially?
Well currently full disclosure,
we are about three years out.
We definitely are not making money.
We are completely venture backed or losing a,
we're very much in the red.
Hopefully one day will,
we will be making money,
but we have a cash commissioned a out of the amount being raised as well as a
small interest in every single company that successfully raises on republic.
So in a way,
if one of the companies that had raised on republic in 10 years,
there's an IPO,
decides Uber,
Airbnb,
then republic would do very well.
Now we're going through an initiative that we aim to tokenize our future revenue
and give them back to every user and investor and partner on republic so that if
and when we get that major distribution that all the hundreds of thousands of
early believers in republic can benefit in that as well monetary wise.
So if I'm investing in ample foods and republic,
I'm also some high investing in republic.
Correct?
So currently not yet.
Currently,
if you invest in ample food and if they get bought out for 10 bucks and you
invest $100 you know,
give or take,
you're going to get about a thousand dollars back.
But very soon we will be giving for,
for making an investment on ample food.
In any project.
Let's say a hundred republic tokens,
each token at one point will represent a portion of future income that republic
takes it.
Okay.
So that imagined back when in the early day,
um,
when Amazon just had 10 companies on the platform and they had given out a
billion tiny little slivers and each sliver represent revenue from each of the
company at the time it may not mean much,
but now 20 years later it can be very substantial.
So
that's very interesting because what I understand from this is that this way for
you to monetize your services for one thing tells us that you are,
you will have skin in the game of the companies that are on your platform,
that you believe in them enough that you took a small share yourselves.
And the system also allows you to create the transaction system that is
completely a zero cost,
right?
Like,
like if I have a share of any company on your platform and in five years they
are really doing super well.
I can divide my,
my token in as many as I want because it's intrinsically,
uh,
divide.
Dividable are you say you can infinitely divided and then transfer this to
anyone globally in the world without any overhead or expense.
Am I right in understanding this?
Yes.
Uh,
how Ma,
how much or how into how many pieces you break it down.
Uh,
and who to granted it to.
That's the realm of token economics and the different ways of incentivizing
people would absolutely.
Back when we were still a private company,
I'm an employee holding a thousand shares.
Um,
in order for her to transfer it to her sister,
say in Singapore,
um,
first you got to get the consent of the company,
then you have to go through the transfer agent,
then you have to sign probably about four set of documents.
Both counterparty signing the company would need to do background check,
Kyc AML on the sister.
And that's why that process is so inefficient.
That transfer of private securities,
even today's heavily,
heavily limited blockchain technology and the new application of it in the
months and the years to come will make that process even more seamless than
public stock trading today.
Um,
and I think again,
it would just bring that more of that energy that fit into this burden,
uh,
companies around the war.
Mm.
Um,
I don't want to talk about the offer side of the equation.
So we ran around,
we talked about uh,
how you orchestrate the platform we talked and what liberated this initiative on
the basis of technology and regulation changing.
We talked about the,
the,
the part of the people who need funds.
We talked a little bit about the part of the,
of the,
the investors.
Let's say tomorrow I want to monetize something that has never been monetized
before.
So let's take an example that at Google we talk about a lot or we hear about a
lot,
which is our data.
People say to me all the time,
how about my data?
It has value,
you know,
a,
and you use that value and there's a huge conversation because I think they gain
value against that value from using the services for free.
And it has,
it's a topic from DC to year,
uh,
down into the private citizen.
Yes.
Right now it's,
it's like a very top of mind topic for everyone,
especially in this day and age.
So let's say tomorrow populations wanted to monetize their data,
right?
That they would say,
right,
let's create a platform,
uh,
together to put our data together.
Maybe individually my data is not worth so much,
but maybe as part of,
I dunno,
uh,
my income level in,
on the west coast or a,
I'm France was part of the French community living abroad or you know,
any identity.
Maybe some companies would be interested in purchasing some of my data.
Could I use a platform like republic and the new regulation and the arrival of
blockchain to somehow put my data willingly on the market and decide how my data
is going to be purchased,
traded board and so on,
in a way that I feel to be transparent and empowered?
Absolutely.
Certainly not on republic today because we're currently a more of an investment
platform,
but there are two elements of blockchain technology that would,
in my opinion,
so of,
uh,
in major ways or in meaningful ways the data privacy concern.
One is that security but decentralized so that you don't have to worry about a
central party holding or relevant information getting hacked.
And so that in and of itself does ease the security concern.
And the second one,
one of the main,
using probably my own psychological attachment or assessment of this particular
data question.
And I think that even though yes,
I agree to the terms,
but I didn't know quite that I was consenting to providing all of these personal
information and data to a couple central parties.
And I'm certainly not feeling like I'm being incentivized by,
if you apply a token economy around it and enable people to make money when our
share in that,
that economic value of data and the choice to opt out,
I think you're going to get so much opting in that net net,
it benefits everyone and it's still serve that same purpose of using data to
analyze,
to produce and put out better products that serve,
you know,
human at large as a,
as a community.
All right.
So I took a very extreme case because very Demetria realized or people's data.
But what I understand from this discussion of to now is that the shift in
paradigm that you're here to talk to us about is both democratizing the
investment and what is being proposed for investments and creating this new
space in which people for the price of a lottery ticket could actually apply a
value to their values,
value to their commitments,
participate to things that are already there and that are already started and
visible and gain the traction of our investment.
And that this is probably going to profoundly reshape the way we create
monetization out of various elements of,
of investment that today are still believed to be very restricted,
to assist them with a cost base with knowledge and expertise and that maybe
tomorrow all these things are going to fly out the window and will be available
for a lot of people truly democratized
100%.
Um,
I think the next Facebook,
um,
the first investors in the next Facebook should not be pdf views of the world,
but be the 500 door maids of the founders.
Hopefully it doesn't have to be a Harvard.
It can be a women's College of Pakistan and that the next wave of founders can
be a single mom in Ecuador reading about it and putting in 10 and $20.
And that by the time the banks in the venture funds or whatnot get in everyone
else getting more and more and that when there's an IPO event,
like the one that's going to produce a hundred thousand million years in the bay
area,
that they're going to be hundreds of thousands of people benefiting or at the
same time.
So I think the last,
um,
wave of venture capital the last 30 years is reduce,
has lifted 1.3 billion people out of abject poverty in the world.
We've been living in the most,
in a better time than ever before.
But the much of the fruits of it in terms of wealth has gone back to the wealth
ears and the institutions.
If we can engage with courage everyone and make it possible as smaller mail for
everyone to buy in.
I think the world 20 years from now we'll probably be almost like sci fi fiction
with a very little,
uh,
you know,
the wealth is just across the boy and standard of living can be lifted from all
corners of the world.
All right,
well thank you so much.
This was very enlightening.
I love both preparing this with you and having this conversation time for us to
open to the rest of the audience.
Uh,
any question,
any comments,
anything you would like to ask Kendrick please?
So I,
uh,
went,
to the platform and there is one thing that I don't understand here.
Um,
when I invest a certain amount,
do I get equity in the company?
Do I like going 2% of that startup now or how's that?
Does that work?
So each of the deal on the investment,
and thank you so much for,
for joining.
Uh,
each of the Deos on the platform has its own set of terms.
Some of the companies are ready,
venture backed if raised tens of millions of dollars and now they just want to
bring,
provide an opportunity for the customers and fence to get in.
So typically would say evaluation for example,
a document would say that you're investing $1,000 and at the company's valuation
of $10 million.
So usually what investing,
what that means is that later on,
if Google buys that company at 100 million,
then you would get a hundred acts give or take on your own personal investment.
So in a way,
yes,
it's,
it's skin in the game is buying it.
It's not shit.
There's a range of distinction between shares and stock and debt and save in
convertible notes.
But the general thesis is very much the same that if the company does well,
you do well proportional these so as well to contrast against buying a product
or making a loan and get a fixed income return back.
So sharing that success in that Ruth,
I think he's a psychological satisfaction and validation that a lot of people in
tech have experience.
Has that answered your question?
Yes.
And to be very clear for everyone who hears this cause we all understand the
concept of share and being a shareholder.
Uh,
when I invest through republic,
what am I and what do I have?
How do you call this?
What is it?
You are an investor,
okay.
But in most cases you're not a shale who do yet you chose an investor to make it
simple for the company and the founders.
So in Fintech is a confluence of law and regulations and the one hand and
innovation on the end.
So you have a set of laws.
It was written some Ed years ago at the time when the world we live in wasn't
even on anyone's mind and how to apply these rules to make it possible for a
word.
Now that you can have a million investors at a very early stage into it because
of that need do new inch,
Julian's leg,
convertible notes like to save,
et cetera.
But you are an investor shareholder not is far less material.
But typically at one point you will become a shareholder and then you get paid
out in cash show.
All right.
So,
and what would be that point?
Like when do you make the,
the shift from being an investor to being a shareholder?
Yep.
So,
uh,
the instrument that we created to make it possible for founders and companies to
deal with so many people is that if and when they experience a liquidity event,
meaning a merger acquisition or going IPO,
then they will convert everyone into shareholders.
And then because you're a shareholder,
you get payout or get cashed out and then leave the company.
All right.
Because otherwise if you keep 10 million shareholders and the cap table,
the cost of administering it is exceedingly high to comply with corporate law.
All right.
Very good.
Thank you so much for the question.
Very,
very good question.
I thank you so much for your detailed answer.
I have a question or I see or initial coin offerings.
It's a mini startups are doing that in the last few years and uh,
frankly most of them are scams.
You're not late.
You're a client to get 10 $20 million and then nothing anything.
Then as he started regulating that for,
for bigger ICLS.
So what,
what's your view on the smaller ones which are still happening and even sitting?
Can volumes sometimes or one word?
Uh,
I think that's a great question.
Um,
you know,
when the ICO boom in 2017 in 2016,
um,
it gave all of us at republic,
you know,
warm and fuzzy feelings all over because it's a true real life validation of our
model in the future where thousands of individuals and not venture capitalist
finance,
random projects and companies not here in silicon valley,
not out of Google but can be out of Singapore or wherever.
So crowd investing in its best form was ICO back in 2020 16 now it was done in a
noncompliant way with us securities law.
So the law caught on.
And so now you apply laws and regulations,
many of which are meant to prevent fraud and scams perpetuated on the investing
public.
But it does come with bells and whistle.
So it makes it a little bit more difficult for people to participate,
know your customer,
anti money laundering and whatnot.
So you seeing a,
in many ways a healthy contraction of that type of financial product.
But at republic we tried to make that compliant in easy and get back to one
point when a credible project can braise 10,
$20 million without having to go and pound the pavement on sand hill road
because she happens to be not living in America and not economically possible to
do that.
Um,
so I'm very optimistic about blockchain technology and startups that are built
or leverage that technology in the long run.
Uh,
and republic itself is applying some of that as well.
Oh,
and I wanted also to,
you know,
highlight something and I will just let you answer to this,
but you could say I'd republic,
we do this and republic with the only you in a garage in Palo Alto,
uh,
or it could be a,
you know,
a bigger team.
So can you tell us a little bit more about,
you know,
under the hood,
like your organization,
how many people you are,
where they are located?
Uh,
this one
definitely.
I,
uh,
I was a general counsel for Angel List and we spun out and set up shop in New
York because that's the seat of the capital market.
And most people still have never invested privately.
Uh,
so our team probably slightly different than a lot of true tech startup in the
valley,
but we're pretty equal purposely.
So between engineering business and then obviously compliance being an
investment company are,
there are about 50 of us,
uh,
have most of the New York,
there's a small office in services school among the team,
just seven former too.
And he's turned business or engineer,
uh,
to navigate this confluence of legal and innovation.
Um,
and uh,
we have a mildly distributed team,
but there's still a core team based out of new,
yeah.
All right.
So I'm,
I'm here.
What I,
what I meant to,
to get from you,
which I do get,
is that this is not just
your,
or are two or three people in a garage.
And he sees that like,
so did you get enough organized already that you have some very serious people
in every department of this making sure that this work,
this is tenable,
this efficient and compliant anyway?
Oh,
absolutely.
Because we're so heavily regulated for touching retail investor.
I think we've been audited.
Something like that does in terms by Finra and sec in two and a half years,
it was why we were so many lawyers in house.
Um,
we have under Business Benj people who've background experience at black rock at
Mckinsey,
one of our founding advisor founded the Malala Fund whose worked God Malala the
Nobel Peace Prize.
So,
uh,
influence servers and what have you,
chase and kid,
the athlete is a chameleon near the wrapper,
uh,
both,
advisors and influencers for us.
So to do and to build on this vision,
it takes more than a village.
It takes partnership and,
uh,
the goodwill of people across all different sectors of society.
I know that it's very hard to determine a valuation of a company,
particularly very early on.
So,
uh,
what does republics involvement in valuing a company before they,
create an offering on your site?
And how will that scale as you have thousands or millions of companies platform?
Uh,
thanks again for the question and valuation in due diligence.
So in the past two and a half years,
we've gotten,
I think by now almost 5,000 applications and we've done due diligence on,
depending on the level of due diligence,
but not all of them.
And we've launched less than 5%,
uh,
on republic.
When it comes to valuation,
there's actually no real math,
particularly for an early company,
your evaluations,
whatever investors are willing to invest in you.
So we typically look at if they have raised money before,
then use that as a potential point of data.
It may have never raised money before.
Then we want to make sure that it is at least in line with the current
ecosystem.
To give you an example,
YC startups typically raised at about 10,
$15 million in valuation.
Pre-Product premarket just to do in New York,
the same team out of New York City would be probably 25,
30% less in valuation because venture capitalists in New York aren't just as
willing to fund a company.
There's value at 15 million pre market.
So applying all of these relative lens that we pass a reasonableness and it's
still up to the founders to do the work and convince investors and strangers and
families and friends to make that investment.
Kendrick,
what are some of the challenges of expanding these investment opportunities to
international markets outside of the u s
Oh,
thanks Colby.
Uh,
on our platform today,
the companies have to be based in the u s when now,
even though we have partnership with different platforms in order continents,
but we have investors from like 30 or 40 countries around the world investing on
Republic,
uh,
going back to a writer,
tried steam in the good ideas exists everywhere.
Um,
I really look forward to today where,
you know,
people here and in New York,
uh,
at lunchtime,
go on it.
Look at a bunch of companies in Africa or Latin America.
And this our small amount and happened to build and make meaningful businesses
that create jobs in those regions.
Uh,
so the future is very much global when it comes to entrepreneurship.
so you talk about my,
you invest in and you must 20 set of dollars,
uh,
company.
Uh,
but given the high bs of early stage startups,
one has too many,
most a 100 200 companies to everybody should the VSM written.
So how do you find the average John Doe can manage such a large portfolio?
Uh,
when it comes to the very high rates of angel investing,
the name of the game is diversification as you mentioned.
So on Angel List as an example,
at the minimum amount,
usually it's higher than a thousand dollars,
but the lowest is got to be $1,000.
That's a lot of money for most people in this world.
If you can reduce that down to $100 and allow $10 investment into 10 companies,
that changes the landscape of things.
And hopefully at one point we can even bring it down to like $5 at $2 and my
family immigrated here from Vietnam.
And I remember when we first moved here,
my mom used to send back like a hundred dollars a month to a couple of her
sisters.
The transaction fee on that transaction was I think 13 or $14 to the sister in a
larger city and like $17 to someone in a smaller town,
which is absurd.
But it was,
that's what everyone lived with.
Now in a day,
given a Vietnam is very warm to like crypto technology,
you can make the same transaction in the fee be less than a dollar.
So,
and we're too where like 2:00 AM into this new day.
So I have no doubt that a couple of years out,
a person with a $50 saving,
not the money that she needs to put food on the table would be able to deploy
the $50 into 10 or 20 companies and still potentially get a meaningful return
out of it.
Net,
the,
is this micro transaction model really better than the Angel List Syndicate
model where you have some professional that goes in and vets the invest like the
companies a little better first because we know that even some of the best
investors don't actually succeed better than the s and p 500.
So
the question about,
uh,
venture validation and a lead investing is addressed in two different ways.
Just because you allow my co investing,
it doesn't mean that you wouldn't have that validation.
So I think 27 or 28% of the companies on republic had been venture backed,
so already went through that Lens.
Now on the other hand,
the problem with venture investing is that a fund Lysa Coya would only pick
startups that they think potentially can you them the proverbial Unicorn 50 acts
at the very least,
20 x five acts not interesting.
It's not enough that fits into the economic model.
If you have two founders building a business in east Oakland,
they will never be more than a $20 million company.
But that creates 500 jobs for single moms in East Oakland.
And you happen to just want to support that particular business and get two or
three acts back that currently you don't have that,
that avenue on Angel List with an eventual fund.
So I view entrepreneurship and investing,
it has to be Silicon Valley's then a lot of good,
but there's like v two,
we now ready flight.
That next stage that people have a say in the type of businesses they get
finance and that will create a word we will live in,
in 10 years from now.
Uh,
you mentioned that republic will take a portion of other companies that are on
your platform.
Can you share what that is and is that consistent for each company?
Yeah,
so currently I'm just going to use a very specific use case.
So there's a,
a company that raise on republic,
uh,
when we first launched six months out and now she has gone on to raise
additional capital from VC.
The founder,
I'm a Latina mom who was working for a corporate,
uh,
incorporate for grocery chain,
doesn't have a technical background,
doesn't fit the lens of someone who would get venture vacuum.
And she just needed that 50,
$60,000 to bill out the first model,
hire a,
you know,
an engineer and a business person and grow.
So we were like,
all right,
we think that she's incredible and resilient and her experience saving money is
so relevant to building a business.
So we launch a campaign and she raised about $80,000.
A lot of it was financed by,
you know,
Latino American professionals in the bay area and beyond,
out of that $80,000,
uh,
the,
the time and money that we've deployed into,
it was probably,
I'm going to guess 20,000 it'd being the very first project,
but the math is that we get 6% out of their mouth successfully raised.
So 6% of 80,000 plus we get a security interest in her company worth 2% of the
amount raised.
So in this case is $1,600 worth of her equity if she,
she's building an employment training platform that trains very low level
employees to mid level management,
the shopping bag cashier at Safeway and lucky into assistant manager.
If she somehow becomes the linkedin of the world,
that 1.6099999999999999 $1,600 take.
We have maybe worth millions.
And if that's the case,
we're going to send that back to investors.
Thank you so much.
Can for joining.
And I want to thank you for two things.
The first thing is sharing with us your knowledge and your,
and your experience and your,
you know,
your company's history and life and mission,
which was very interesting.
And the other thing also is I want to thank you for sharing your story because
it's very inspiring.
You being,
you know,
coming from Vietnam,
having grown to be a a Stanford fellow at Stanford low,
uh,
becoming an entrepreneur,
connecting back to the world,
giving it back to the world as,
you know,
what we'll,
we,
we really embrace diversity.
We want not only diversity but inclusion.
Like it's not only euro in the nightclub which were invited to dance,
right?
So inclusion and what everything you say,
uh,
speeds a positive lights on,
on the world,
uh,
on how it's doing and high is going to become and on these values that we hold
very dear.
And you're living example of those values,
connecting technology to good business,
too.
Good too good value on initiatives from people respecting what we call here,
respecting the opportunity,
uh,
and all this in great ethics and transparency.
So thank you for all of this.
It was a pleasure having you.
I'm so thrilled to have had you today.
You know,
and I'm looking forward to everything that's going to happen for republic in the
coming years and I want to wish you the best of success.
Thank you so much.
Bryce is truly an honor to be here and I want to thank everybody we will for
having me.
I think the model of do good,
uh,
is something that's like close to my heart.
Uh,
Google is the first company that put to good to get it with profit and that's
what gave rise to republic.
And you know,
on the personal level is incrementally,
we do what we can to live up to something that you guys have perpetuated or
throughout the globe.
So thank you so much.
All right.
Pleasure.
Thank you,
Eric.
Thank you.